Is it possible for a person to take too many supplements?
Yes, it is.
So for sure it is, it's even more probable
than a person's taking incorrect supplements.
So I think I have a blog post.
I think I have a blog post on minerals
I did it a number of years ago.
It's worth looking at it.
That's what we see a lot.
I think it's good to evaluate your supplements.
A lot of people will be taking like a multiple mineral
or a multiple vitamin.
And it's got things in it that nobody should be consuming.
Here's an example I just had a chat with somebody
this morning that was put on folic acid.
Well, folic acid as folic acid, folic acid
is synthetic folic, understand?
So it was named folic acid when they synthesized it back
in the I think the 1950s when they discovered folate.
Remember folate is the B vitamin that's
found in foliage hence the name.
So in green leafy vegetables, folate is found.
So they found that folate deficiencies
called caused neural tube defects.
Facts with women were pregnant with babies
and they had folate deficiency.
So they synthesized folate in the laboratory
called it folic acid.
So folic acid, would you look at a label
and says folic acid as folic acid?
Then it's synthetic folate.
Some companies will still say folic acid
as methyl tetrahedral folate, that it's the right folate
or folic acid as folic acid and folidate.
Then it's the right folic acid.
However, there's still a lot of companies out there
that really don't care about what they put in their supplements
they only care about cell-lead supplements.
So more than taking too many supplements, which that can be
a problem, I see people taking incorrect things
or poor quality supplements, poor quality minerals,
elemental minerals, oh boy, that's like just poison
for your body.
I have blog posts on that as well.
So look that up, correct type of minerals,
how it should be taken way you'd eat it in nature,
double bonded to an amino acid, how you'd eat it
in a vegetable or in a good quality grass-fed beef,
how you'd get it in that, not how you'd it from the grog.
We don't eat dirt to get our minerals.
And then taking supplements, you talk about too many supplements,
taking supplements incorrectly based
upon your condition.
You see cancer patients taking copper?
No, cancer patients not take copper.
Copper is a growth support.
It will stimulate growth, cell growth, cell replication.
Cancer patients should not take a lot of methyl groups.
For reasons that methyl groups can silence tuber suppressor genes
and you need healthy function of your tuber suppressor genes
if you're going to stimulate intrinsic apoptosis of cancer
cells.
Cancer patients shouldn't be taking antioxidants
if you're trying to kill cancer.
If you already know you have cancer, you should change your,
there's things that you should do if you don't have cancer
and there's totally different things you should do
if you were diagnosed with cancer.
There's things that you do if you have a heart disease
and totally different things that you should do
if you have cancer, you have cancer,
should not be taking nitric oxide.
If you have heart disease but not cancer,
nitric oxide can be extremely beneficial.
If you're trying to prevent cancer, antioxidants
are a very wise thing to be taking.
But if you already have cancer, you shouldn't be taking
antioxidants because you want to create a pro oxidative stress
to a cancer cell in order to kill it.
So there's, it really depends on your condition.
You should conduct, you should have, you know,
communication with the practitioner who knows these things.
And unfortunately, I talked to a lot of people
that come from practitioners that have a serious disease
and there are other things that they should not be taking
that could actually be promoting their cancer.
And that's not a wise thing.
So you've got to talk to somebody who knows
what they're doing for that condition
because it is very different.
I just wish it was just real simple
but it's not, it's just not that simple.
So